et franchement j'ai vu des rêves de
gamins ici je ne masse les gens que
j'aime mais ils disent oui et viennent
c'est joli Pietri merci
[Applaudissements]
on en parlera mais Julie vous savez
Jeanne masque elle est venue ici et
toujours les têtes les attaches qui non
mais ils veulent pas chanter tout ça non
non mais ça c'est pour attacher de
presse ici c'est ici ça ne marche à
chanter j'ai pleuré si Julie Pietri
chante je pleure on se fait quoi on se
fait on se fait amoureux
[Applaudissements]
alors ça te fait un
fou amoureux à mourir
[Musique]
un peu
ni le jour Niort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore celle-là est-ce que c'est vrai
alors
est-ce que c'est vrai qu'après c'est
parce que c'est vous qui a voulu chanter
caberlon renard et après il devait y
avoir un album mais de ce qu'on m'a dit
il entend ta pas été folle folle et du
coup vous l'avez pas fait c'est pas non
c'est pas l'exact histoire c'est que en
effet on devait faire un album sauf que
moi très rapidement je voulais partir de
la maison de 10 dans laquelle j'étais
celle de chez là et avec le même
producteur qui était quand même
quelqu'un très relou
et donc je suis partie avec un protocole
qui n'était pas vraiment très égalitaire
et je vais laisser un peu toutes mes
royalties
[Musique]
oui parce qu'il avait besoin un petit
peu de s'acheter je sais pas une
moumoute de plus
mais en tout cas moi ma liberté n'avait
pas de prix et j'avais déjà découvert
une équipe extraordinaire et c'est là
que j'ai sorti mon album le premier jour
avec Ève lève-toi une nouvelle vie quand
même ça faisait quoi j'ai été très je me
souviens plus
tout le monde
allons-y chez vous
avec la vie
alors du coup voilà
est venu jusqu'à moi je rêve toi des
enfants grandis
je serai là
[Applaudissements]
un peu mais nous les trucs modernes et
tout tu ne coûte un mec qui te met du
Tulip Pietri et du Jeanne Mas et tout et
la soirée elle décolle un peu non avant
la chanson et c'est vous qui l'avez
écrit dans plus oui je suis aussi auteur
on parle peu souvent de ça chez les
femmes donc vous êtes millionnaire
nativement ça vous intéresse c'est
célibataire
je suis célibataire et je peux être
hétérosexuel contre de l'argent
je préfère une sonnerie à un homme
pauvre c'est tout ce que je dis
non mais surtout vous êtes magnifiques
franchement alors il y a eu
effectivement bon on va parler toute la
carrière déjà je sais pas si vous avez
en ce moment il y a le retour de la Star
Ac Yama singer il y a The Voice est-ce
que toutes ces émissions ça vous amusera
un petit peu de les faire par exemple
The Voice dans le jury ou Star Academy
si vous avez appelé moi j'aurais adoré
oui ou The Voice ou même comme je ne
sais pas comme prof de chant non mais on
l'a vu entraîner des gens des jeunes oui
j'adore ma singer un bob l'éponge vous
l'auriez fait
pour les deux moi généralement
je sais pas mais ça doit être très sympa
c'est très bien mais c'est très bien que
vous tapiez pas dessus et que je m'en
fiche dans la mesure où il faut chanter
déjà donc ça c'est pas mal c'est quand
même mon métier
et est-ce que vous trouvez est-ce que
vous trouvez est-ce que vous avez aimé
votre carrière est-ce que vous avez une
belle carrière
je n'ai pas conscience bah si parce que
vous avez dit récemment j'aurais adoré
avoir mon René Angélil j'aurais fait une
carrière internationale
[Musique]
j'ai manqué un peu dans manager qui me
rassure un peu qui conduisent un peu
voilà René je trouve qu'il avait un
talent extraordinaire et je pense
vraiment que ça m'aurait aidé à être
oui peut-être
un tel succès qu'il a été traduit dans
beaucoup de langues ça faisait comment
Eve en anglais
[Musique]
après je sais plus merde
mais non il y a eu des moments alors
Jacques années 80 vous connaissez des
succès rapides et tout de suite 90 on va
honnête il y a une petite période un peu
creuse et pourquoi pourquoi
mais ma fille Manon est née en 92 et
j'ai pas eu envie de me montrer avec le
bide comme ça voilà ça c'est pas rester
disant quand même Julie pas moi ça peut
pas rester en fin de 10 ans de pas un
éléphant
les années 90 c'était plus compliqué on
va dire un petit peu la vérité
ça peut arriver enfin comme on dit je
suis tombé enceinte ça m'amuse toujours
cette expression bah et j'avais
absolument pas envie de vendre mon
ventre dans les magazines donc ça c'est
mon problème je me suis donc
cachée une carrière un peu compliqué
vous dites d'ailleurs la gloire l'argent
personne ne savait mais ma vie privée
était chaotique la rupture avec mon
producteur compagnon on était séparés il
supportait pas que je sois enceinte d'un
autre il me harcèlementalement et même
proposé un mariage en trio j'ai fait une
tentative de suicide en prenant des
médicaments c'est vrai ça c'est vrai
mais non producteur mon producteur à
l'époque était qui était mon compagnon
presque mon mari m'a proposé d'ailleurs
le mariage quand je suis parti avec
quelqu'un d'autre et que j'étais déjà
enceinte mais est-ce que c'était une
époque où les femmes les artistes femmes
n'étaient pas j'allais dire autant
respecté qu'aujourd'hui était ça ou pas
évident vous savez très bien que notre
métier c'est un métier pourri pour les
femmes et ça continue ça continue mais
ça continue sur la carrière par exemple
star 80 vous dites bah c'est une honte
mais certains chanteurs des hommes
notamment étaient payés 20% de plus je
pense un peu à Jean-Luc Lahaye si nous
regarde ou pas
peu importe mais les hommes sont
certains hommes étaient payés plus que
les femmes ah oui parce que c'est des
hommes ou parce que c'était des stars
plus importantes parce que des hommes
soient payés 20 aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
non non toujours 20% de moins toujours
toujours mais non
pas sur les tournées tout ça si encore
aujourd'hui
sur ce genre de tournée oui sur ce ou
les ou les gens sont mélangés les mettre
plus que les filles et à carrière régale
si ce n'est en ce qui me concerne plus
alors vous avez vendu plus de disques
que certains ah bah oui 12 millions j'ai
dit tout à l'heure 12 millions c'est
c'est gigantesque que je vois quelques
chiffres d'Eve par exemple c'était 7
millions enfin c'est vraiment c'est une
très très belle carrière et qui continue
il y a le nouvel album je mets les pieds
dedans deux minutes parce que vraiment
on s'aime je le sens
pas comme ça mon cœur non non je te sens
venir
parce que je dis que vous êtes une femme
me too que vous faites avancer les
choses vous les dites sur les salaires
et je trouve que j'étais RTL le jour où
jean-luclay a dit cette horreur voulait
pas que je couche avec Jean-Luc Julie
Pietri que je me j'aurais pu le gifler
parce que c'est un goujat mais ce qui
m'intéresse et c'est ça que je ne
comprends pas vous avez porté plainte et
vous avez bien fait et derrière c'est
pas moi c'est vous qui êtes dans la
presse j'ai porté plainte contre lui
pour dire moins de 40.000 euros et c'est
normal mais derrière vous fonctionnement
mais vous dites derrière j'ai retiré ma
plainte parce qu'il y avait il y avait
des pressions mais de qui il y en a tout
a été dit mais dépression de qui de la
tournée Star à 80 quand j'ai connu tous
je peux vous dire que ça va ça va tomber
hein
on vous a dit que tu retires toi tu as
plein ou tu sors de la de tu sors de la
tournée c'est pas vrai
c'est que les éléphants sont moins payés
et que et qu'une femme on lui dit tu
retires ta plainte ou tu dégages de la
tournée oui ce que j'entends là me fait
une honte et du coup vous avez préféré
retirer la plante
elle devait chanter j'imagine
pas que le fait que j'aurais pu en effet
on a dû te le vendre du genre il a dit
ça c'est une connerie le pensais pas
c'est pas ça c'était c'était une
question de pouvoir il y avait des gens
de pouvoir qui pouvaient être peut-être
et vous dites aussi dans la presse donc
c'est pas moi et je ferme cette
parenthèse désagréable mais qui est très
utile je vous promets tout ce que vous
dites c'est très utile pour les femmes
et moi ça m'a beaucoup touchée à
quelqu'un qui a écrit Eve lève-toi et
danse avec la vie on femme unique donc
je peux pas vous dire bien sûr ah c'est
rose qu'est-ce qu'on est qu'est-ce qu'on
est bien dans ce monde moi je suis je
suis pas du tout une battante je vais me
laisser faire
ben j'essaye de pas me laisser faire
puis parfois
vous dites que ce métier a été difficile
comme ça a été pour France Gall comme ça
a été pour plein plein de femmes
effectivement qui ont démarré mais pour
finir avec lui effectivement
une seconde on va faire la soirée non
question mais vous l'avez dit dedans et
ça m'intéresse parce que c'est important
vous avez dit quand je faisais la
tournée tout le monde savait à propos de
Jean-Luc Lahaye et tout le monde ferme
sa gueule vous l'avez dit je ne sais pas
non c'est vous qui l'avez dit mais vous
ne confirmez très bien merci est-ce que
c'est pas parce que on parle de la
tournée Star 80 est-ce que c'est pas
plus sur la tournée Âge tendre et tête
de bois qui a eu des problèmes aussi moi
j'ai suivi un peu cette tournée à
l'époque on m'a dit que ça avait été
très compliqué avec d'autres artistes
comme Sheila comme Hervé Vilard il y
avait une telle concurrence entre eux je
peux vous dire que je l'ai fait pendant
un an et j'ai fait trois croisières avec
tous ces gens et ils étaient tous très
affables très élégant c'est qui votre
meilleur ami dans tout ce groupe à peu
près Hervé
vilarderai je l'adore
aussi qu'à la fin des années 90 quand ça
marche un petit peu moins bien vous avez
la version Eve un peu techno un peu dans
les bois de gay et c'est ça qui vous a
qui vous a relancé totalement le fait
que je sois revenu cette plutôt dans les
années 2000 en 2003 ou 4 je ne sais plus
j'ai fait une émission sur une chaîne
concurrente sur absolument et vous avez
gagné quand j'ai gagné pour le meilleur
de Johnny et visiblement ça a plus
majorité de public et c'est toujours le
public qui a raison voilà
et vous savez que ce que vous venez de
faire tout à l'heure chanter en live
comme ça en général aucun artiste ne
veut le faire mais aucun aucun c'était
incroyable retour gagnant je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez je lui dis mais moi
je présentais et que Jean-Pierre
Foucault à l'époque
comme ça je me rappelle
souvenir parce que ça m'a permis de
remettre le pied au d'étrier et de
revenir sur le devant de la scène
extrêmement ému parce que effectivement
c'est le public qui vous avez choisi et
je me souviens que je vous avais emmené
à l'époque sur le plateau d'ailleurs ah
c'est vous
je me souviens que c'est très
désagréable je me souviens que Julie
vous étiez tout tremblante vous étiez
tellement ému et vous me disiez mais
c'est dingue c'est dingue ils m'ont
choisi mon choix vous avez tapé sur mon
épaule en faisant Julie Julie c'est vous
et je discutais avec patrick Coutin qui
est un ami et avec lequel j'ai fait un
duo d'ailleurs dans le dernier album
origami voilà le choix absolument voilà
et en effet j'étais très aimé parce que
franchement je pensais vraiment pas que
j'avais gagné c'était ça fait plaisir
quand même qu'on te voit que le public
tout le monde aujourd'hui mission vous
fait gagner
c'est génial on se dit comme disait
l'actrice que je ne suis pas tout à fait
morte
mais j'ai pas envie de mourir non
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que je suis maladroit non mon
cœur non je veux dire que quand ça
marche un petit peu moins bien on se dit
que finalement les gens nous aiment
toujours autant ben oui je pense que
j'ai la chance de perdre durée
de mal moi aussi j'ai eu un moment très
délicat et puis et puis c'est revenu
l'album est là l'album est là et ce qui
est vrai c'est que vous chantez dans les
stars 80 mais ça ils sont souvent très
nombreux sur scène surtout et là
exactement vous chantez toute seule mais
ça on l'avait pas oublier donc vous
remontez sur scène pour faire des 40 ans
de carrière avec une tournée
anniversaire origami tour le 2 octobre à
Richelieu le 15 octobre à Châteaudun le
9 décembre à Lille j'adore Lille le 15
décembre à Paris où là une petite
invitation ça fait toujours plaisir
évidemment vous en aurez voilà vous en
aurez j'essaierai de gratin
et l'album qui est là voilà
que j'ai fait en effet c'est que je vais
chanter le 15 décembre ensuite la
tournée va continuer jusqu'à fin 2023
mais le 15 décembre ce sera la nouvelle
Ève c'est un peu exprès bien sûr et vous
savez quoi non mais
quand on aime les gens nous on les vent
très très bien on a un clip vous avez un
clic regardez
[Musique]
des fleurs des fleurs mais où
voyez je ne fais rien qui ressemble
lorsque j'ai fait avant j'essaie
d'innover parce qu'en fait
j'essaie de rester une artiste intègre
telle que je suis
Moix ne paraissaient pas beaucoup moi on
parle beaucoup de moi mais moi je parle
peu je suis venu vous voir aujourd'hui
voilà et moi ce que j'ai tout le temps
c'est un artiste toujours un artiste
même quand ça marche pas j'aimerais
Julie Pietri d'avoir été avec eux merci
merci encore beaucoup je dis que c'était
un plaisir
je vous raccompagne parce que je suis un
homme du monde merci j'adore merci
beaucoup merci encore merci beaucoup
merci merci